my coaching sessions and I thought oh
that's a great thing to do so I also
worked for a tech firm which some of you
will still recognize today but my first
first part of my career was that
Motorola semiconductor product sector
that dates me as well and then about 23
years ago I chose to leave that 16-year
career I have worked up to a personnel
manager that's what we called it back in
the day now it's HR manager and I made a
choice to relocate my young kids to a
better place to live and I quit my job
even though I loved it and Brady today
and I decided I wanted to work at the
University here and that I set my sights
on getting hired there and I had to take
a step back in my career I had a start
over I applied for jobs that what I
thought were my level I wasn't getting
hired and so I really had to do some
soul-searching which we're gonna talk
about today and then you know what it's
worth it I had a little salary
flexibility at the time and I just said
you know what I'm gonna go for it I
don't mind starting over
I was hired as an office specialist and
then within a few years I took on a
benefits manager role and then a few
years after that I became the head of
the department and so I've had some
experience with this I was there for 21
years I led the department for 15 and I
then two years ago made another career
change and for me it was um early
retirement I wanted to spend time with
my husband and travel and my grandkids
and my family and I have learned
coaching about five years ago and I I
loved it and I really wanted to give it
a try and become my own business owner
and so I've been doing that so that's a
little bit about me and why I'm
passionate about this subject so anyway
let's move on so let me hear from you uh
why you signed up today just a few of
you tell us why you came and what you
hope to walk away with today
you
if any up to here if you're hoping to
get out of today's session
wasn't there something made you spy him
oh I'm sorry
type yes type it in the chat I'm sorry
see it makes it easy you don't even have
to speak up you can type it you can make
it short
I wanted this I'm worried about this to
get some motivation great yeah someone
says I'm also changing careers recently
I applied for a job that I was
overqualified for and I did not know how
to best present myself great that's
exactly why we're all here today alright
thank you for sharing all right I'm
returning to ITA after a break of ten
years I have 20 years of software
engineering oh my gosh that's so common
I'm really hearing from a lot of
software engineers these days who are
making a switch you know when we entered
the field or when you enter your field a
long time ago you know technology that's
available today was not in existence
there's so much exciting in the world
today and that's what I'm hearing from
Udacity students is they just want to
get involved and have a more direct
impact so Sam says I am not sure about
my real value on global level if not
limited on my safe zone company area I
may be both over or under qualified
absolutely that's going to change it
most of you a lot of you may be
overqualified five in some areas you're
probably under qualified in and some I'm
planning to take up a new career in
technology I'm afraid of change so
thought this would help me oh yes change
that big change word it is so scary
sometimes all right thank you all for
sharing let's move on all right all
right
so today's agenda we're going to talk
about the over quiet over qualified
applicant issues that come up for us
we're going to talk about employer fears
because believe me they have them when
they meet some of us we're going to talk
about doing some soul-searching and
really digging deep into why do you want
to make the change and all the other
ramifications of that we're going to
make sure that there's integrity in your
decision and that you've really thought
through all the aspects we're going to
talk about your communication strategy
and I'm going to give you a few things
to think about in terms of consistency
and um and demonstrating your confidence
so we're going to talk about we're going
to talk about how you take your skills
that you've built to this point and you
apply them to the new position or the
new direction that you want to go and
then you know if we if we're successful
we're going to talk about how we need to
fulfill that obligation to the new
employer the new box the way that we
presented ourselves and if we do if
we're not successful we're gonna chalk
it up to lessons learned so all of this
is on our agenda today and I'm going to
depend heavily on Brett since this is my
first still meeting webinar um to help
us in the chat answer some of the
questions and feel free to put your
questions out there I'll try to look at
some of it but Brett may weigh in - -
he's got a lot of experience here with
Udacity and I value a lot of what he
shared with me already so all right so
listen I want reasons that one might
apply for a position if you're
overqualified I mean beyond the one
where you just you know you've been
doing something for a long time and you
want to make a change there are things
that have brought you here
so some of you I see this in the chat
some of you are reinsuring the workforce
you might have taken a break for
whatever reason okay sometimes we have
life changes thrust upon us whether it's
raising a family we might have had an
unfortunate layoff or something occur
with our previous employment we might
have decided to go back to school do
something different for a while and so
now we're trying to re-enter that
technology field or or we're coming back
into the workforce after getting our
children in a good place and I hear from
a lot of these folks so um you know no
matter what the reason is that you're
here today I want to just tell you
you're in good company I had a client a
student at Udacity recently say you know
I've been um a product manager for a
long time I've been on the customer end
of things and I really came to Udacity
to deepen my technology understanding
and she said to me you know I just
really want to be able to talk to my
customers a little bit more clearly and
have them trust me that I know what I'm
talking about so that's a great reason
in this case she wasn't really looking
to make a change she was just looking to
get better at what she does okay so
there's all kinds of reasons that could
take her in a different direction Sunday
that wasn't her goal it's time but
there's all kinds into what she said to
me was I'm not really sure if the
Udacity career services are here to meet
for me and I said absolutely they are
you enrolled as a student and you are
studying and completing your degree
you're absolutely entitled to these
coaching and career and no matter what
your circumstances you should take full
advantage of those resources they you're
there
really good I've been in the HR field
for many many years and I'm not seeing
such great resources where I've worked
before so anyway you're really lucky to
have that so again feel in good company
there are you you all have different
reasons why you're here
or at Udacity but you're in good company
so all right so before we actually get
into this topic I want to just take a
step back make this a little more simple
because you know one of the other things
I hear from Udacity students is they're
so much I'm having such a hard time kind
of figuring out where to go next we have
the resume review the cover letter
review the LinkedIn review the github
review all these events and webinars
recorded and in you know live and
there's the student hub and all these
channels and they're just saying gosh
there's so much I don't even know where
to start
um so let me tell you that today's
session is not going to go through the
details of how to write a resume how to
sell yourself in a cover letter how to
network how to do your Linkedin we're
not going to get into the details of
that sir you're out there for you the
value of today's webinar at home is that
you learn how to slightly tweak your
approach when you are doing those things
and you would tweak it because you find
yourself in a situation where you are at
least partially overqualified good job
you searching for for the role that
you're trying to change to and that
means what somebody else said here in
the chat earlier just because you're
overqualified in some aspects
doesn't mean you're fully qualified in
others so what we're going to talk about
today are your lungs and how you're
going to tweak your materials and how
you're going to talk about yourself in
your elevator pitch when you're
networking how you're going to sell
yourself in an interview and how you're
going
you know work through all of these
questions and these applicant concerns
and needs employer fears so that's what
we're gonna spend our time on today and
what I want to tell you is that this is
messy stuff okay we're going to talk
about fears today a little bit and we're
going to talk about concerns and worries
and we're going to talk about thoughts
and feelings and how those lead to
actions and we're going to talk about
integrity and authenticity and we're
going to talk about confidence or lack
of confidence okay and these are very um
these these things are the sort of
things that career coaches can really
help with we can certainly give advice
and we can we can talk about resume
writing and all that but one thing you
need to know about the coaching process
when you sign up for a career coach at
Udacity is that the intent of that is to
have customized solutions for each one
of you all of your circumstances that
have brought you here all of your
experience is unique and so there is no
one-size-fits-all approach to this so
that's the real value of having coaches
added to this mix of career resources
all right so let's get on with it here
let's move on so I listed just a few of
the applicant issues that come up that I
thought of and we talked about those you
know you might have a fear that an
employer is not gonna hire you and we'll
talk about what some of those concerns
might be from the employer side in just
a minute
you might worry a little and I explained
this is gonna look like a backward move
in my career true trajectory how am I
gonna explain this down the road or ha
better yet how am I gonna explain it to
the person I interviewed with when I
finally get that interview in machine
learning they're not gonna understand
this they might think I'm not a good
employers somehow I'm you know I'm
getting kicked out in my current role
it's gonna look like backward progress
in some cases or lateral progress which
you know people make judgments about
that and we worry about those judgments
so salary considerations this is a big
one right hey in some cases it's not
I've talked to some people who's who are
planning on staying with their current
company and their companies have certain
policies where if you make a lateral
move and it benefits the company that
there are no salary cuts
that's an awesome place to work by the
way
but many of us do have to to take a cut
if we make a change the career changes
that I made I certainly had to be ready
to make it financially and not everybody
can do that
depends on your own unique circumstances
whether you can end up with a whether
you can be not only psychologically
satisfied with the lower salary but
financially satisfied right and how long
can you do that and then a real big key
being today that that really I want you
to pay attention to because it's very
important is is your confidence you
might feel a lack of confidence some of
you have been in your roles for 15 20 22
years I've heard I think that was the
longest one so far and you've been
pretty confident lately right because
you've worked up you've progressed in
your career and you're doing good things
in you've gotten past them without an
easy and newness and now you're looking
to make the swinish and you've got
yourself in a place where it feels like
starting over and that can really take a
toll on your level of confidence now
you're in a place where you don't have
everything you need to move forward and
you're having to make those transferable
skills and document all that and get
that ready and convector confident so
those are just some of the applicant
issues so let's just done hear from some
of you on the chat I'm looking what are
some other applicant issues do I get I
missed something on this list I'm sure I
did personal questions
okay some of your questions that you're
posing directly to me I won't be able to
necessarily get to all of those today so
we will sorry let me get back where we
work we'll try to copy those that if I
miss it um feel free to to get on the
student Channel a student hub careers
channel and asks those questions of the
coaches and one of the coaches they'll
get back to you I'll be on there next
Tuesday from at the same time of day
that we're doing right now
so Oh John Mark says wow I have all this
concern okay all right so we're gonna
move on because the number one thing on
this list was what are the employers
worried about okay all right well
they're worried about things like oh
you're just coming here to get
experience or you just want this job so
you can get experience doing this thing
and then you're gonna move on you're
gonna get bored you've been doing this
other thing for so long you've gotten to
such a high place and you're not going
to be satisfied in this position very
long right they're telling themselves
that and you know I've been on the
hiring end of things for a very long
time and I have to tell you that it is
one of the most consistent concerns not
even with people that are perceived to
be overqualified but just people in
general you know people who have a ten
see to move more than they did 30 years
ago and so we wonder as hiring managers
you know what what will it be that will
keep this person contributing here on my
staff why should I hire them looks to me
like they've moved around a lot or
they're overqualified and they're not
going to stay so it is a struggle for us
okay you'll want more pay right we
talked about that from your side you
might need more pay so that you do have
you know we're going to talk about how
you can do some soul-searching on that
topic and then if your body onto this
change then you will need to convince
the employer that pay you know what I
have some celery flexibility in I'm
going to be okay for a while and and
really more than anything I want to
learn this new thing I want to
contribute at a different level whatever
it is it is coming you to make this
change here's a big one some hiring
managers will think that eventually
you're going to want their job and what
if you come in with stellar
qualifications and you've even done more
than they have in their careers and
that's really common there are some
managers where this doesn't bother
they're self-confident enough that they
are not worried about that they know
what it is to build a team and how teams
individual team members come to the
table with complimentary skills and
talents and that's their philosophy of
building a team but there are some
managers who will and they're if they're
not bad managers necessarily they are it
is what it is they they maybe see you as
having the potential to outshine them
maybe you have more background or
experience than they do in certain area
and they just build compromised or
insecure about that so you're gonna face
those things all right what else let me
look at the chat here
why do you want mr. techie also okay
anything else we missed on the employer
fears maybe you've been on the hiring
and I've talked to some of you who do
hire people every day so you have some
experience with this if you do use it to
your advantage
put yourself even if you don't have
experience hiring people you know you
can easily put yourself in this in the
mindset of a hiring manager and
anticipate with some of those concerns
and questions might be alright we're
gonna move on all right here's the
soul-searching I talked about this
before I want you to spend most of your
time and there is a particular order
that you do this in in my opinion you
may have already done some work on your
resume or your LinkedIn and all of that
sign you don't need to worry that it's
not good enough but if you find yourself
in a partially overqualified position or
a job you are speaking I want you to
take a timeout and I want you to ask
yourself these questions and many more
and I want you to be absolutely candid
with yourself about the answers okay
what are your salary requirements how
much do you know about what this is
going to take have you if you know what
job you're after or what change you're
after is it going to require you to take
a salary reduction and itself about how
long all right if you're just trying to
get your foot in the door and then
you're going to instantly look for the
next job that's posted at a higher spot
level that don't you really think hard
about doing this you wouldn't want to do
that to your current employer and I
suggest that you don't want to do that
to a future employer now people have
asked me well how long should I stay in
a role and I would just say there is no
black and white answer to that but if
you are not
hair to stand a roll at least a year and
preferably two then I would really think
hard about whether its transition right
not just for you but for the employer
okay so I have a little bit of an
internet and stability going on here but
hopefully everything's okay all right
so the other important question I think
that Brett got to this on the chat Thank
You Brett why do you really want this
position
you better know the answer to that
question before you even start what is
it about that you're so passionate about
doing it's causing you to make this
change but that you really love about
the change that you're making what will
be different for you when you get there
and what might be different for the
world if you were to be able to put your
skills to use I hear this all the time
can lead a city students they just say I
want to make a bigger impact on the
future generations there's so much
exciting stuff there and I just want to
do some hands-on work with that I want
to have a more direct role in life I'm
too far removed it's not meaningful for
me anymore
okay jot down the answers to this as you
are thinking through this that take
notes on all of this because you will
use those notes as you put the rest of
your materials together and as you
prepare for your interview and your
elevator pitch it's very important
are you prepared to do the things that
you have I want you to realize what
someone said earlier is just because
you're overqualified in some areas
doesn't mean you're overqualified for
the entire job that you're seeking or
the career change that you're looking to
make you need to really Zone in on
are the critical aspects of that career
change what is it they're looking for
that you don't have that you need to
either translate from your past
experience and demonstrate your learning
capabilities and confidence and convince
them that you can do this even if you
don't know everything right now and what
is it you really need to build in your
project portfolio what are the skills
you need to deepen how are you going to
get that experience okay and then
finally how can you have value in a
different level okay this is this is
really important and you need to have
some things figured out on this before
you start interviewing what will it be
like for you to be at a different level
maybe you've been involved in the
decision-making of a company for a very
long time or maybe at least a few years
and you really like that leadership role
or you like that higher level
contribution what if you don't have that
direct line of sight for a while what is
it that you're going to do in this new
role that will help you feel satisfy at
least for a year or two now and how can
you contribute this is this is really
important it isn't all about you you you
if it is also about the value
proposition that you group into the
employer what is it that you say you
know what are their interests and hire
you you have to make it in their best
interest to hire you and you and to
convince them you have to convince
yourself how can you add value maybe
you've been in a leadership role so
maybe you know how to help others maybe
you're really good at giving credit and
helping develop people so even if you're
not in a supervisory role maybe you can
figure out how to help others be
successful and maybe that will give you
a meaningful satisfaction whatever it is
you need to be able to articulate that
and then I would ask you a question
about job growth if you see job
Oh vertical progression upward
progression I would ask you to challenge
yourself on that point I will tell you
firsthand that every single career
change that I have made in my life the
big two that I talked to you about
involved something lateral or backwards
and I learn from every in fact I worked
at a grocery store here locally when I
came up here from from Motorola because
I was trying to find a job and I
I hung tags on a shelf and while that
certainly wasn't as challenging as the
HR Manager role I had before I found
things to make that challenging for me
some of it was about efficiency some was
about repeatable solutions son was about
making things better at the place I
worked for the customers so figure out
what you can do to not only add value
for the employer but also to feel
satisfied and have a purpose okay all
right
I'm sure I missed some things layered in
my notes but that's okay I think you
guys are coming up with some I try to
give a lot of different values that I
get blocked okay so the son this is one
thing I did forget to say is this is the
ideal kind of thing to have a coach help
you with now you can get started on your
own if you get stuck it's a great thing
you can schedule a session with one of
the career coaches and it can help you
work through it or you can start with a
career coach and then keep working
through it yourself there's no
particular order here but it is that
kind of thing that we coaches do best
because we're trained to help you dig
deep and we help you uncover sometimes
the hidden things maybe we get insights
from the conversation and we ask more
questions and we help you uncover what
might be a little maybe not so
yes so if a one point I want to make
before we go into the next slide is that
you if you cannot authentically answer
these questions and feel good about it
you really need to think about if this
is the right time or the right move for
you if you're getting a strong gut
reaction about one or all of these spend
some time with a colleague someone in
your network whose made a change maybe
even use a coach and really work through
that sometimes at the end of the day you
just have to say you know and I'm still
gonna keep working on my degrees and I'm
gonna keep deepening my skills and I'm
going to keep watching for a different
opportunity but I really cannot I am you
know I'm the sole earner my family I
can't take the kind of salary cut that
it's going to require me to make such a
drastic transition and I really need to
rethink this and maybe take a more
subtle and longer time to make this
transition okay all right
all right so I do want to point out that
let me find my place here
post it here
okay so while we're not going to spend a
lot of time on resumes and writing cover
letters and all this per se today
because you have all those resources
available to you and the coaches can
help you with that too I do want you to
spend some time after you've answered
all those questions and if you're still
bought in on this change you do need to
build a rapport you need to learn how to
document and articulate your
transferable skills in an interview and
in your letter you need to be able to
demonstrate how your past success has
helped you learn how to problem solve
and work through things where the where
it's gray area and you know those are
the things you can do I mean you really
can be an asset in a new room or with a
new employer in a new role and you need
to figure out how to articulate the
advantage to that employer in a lot of
regards it's like maybe how some other
coaches have put this and you really do
have to do the work for the employer and
that will get you noticed so anyway all
right so being able to kind of on a
translating your experience I think
Jackie's been out there one of our
coaches been out there this week posting
tips about transferable skills we have
another coach he's going to do a webinar
like this Mira is gonna do a webinar on
December 11 about soft skills and that's
ideal those are those are really good
things to those kinds of things like
leadership and and teamwork and and
collaboration and communication those
are some of the soft skills that we all
have and being able to talk about you
know
and this well for many years and I spent
a lot of time working on teams and I
learned about team conflict and
particularly with an employer who you
know has a culture that is based on
teamwork you know and then talk about
how you can use that in this job that
you're applying for you know I
understand what it means to be a team
contributor and how to share credit and
help my colleagues be successful they're
things like that that for many companies
will just be like wow for them they'll
be really excited that they have someone
like you but again it's got to be real
it's got to be authentic and you got to
really believe it and if you don't don't
sell yourself that way all right so
really what you're doing there is you're
reframe reframing you're taking
situations that you've had in the past
and you're thinking like this in ways
that fit this particular job and you
know if your person that remembers best
by writing things down
write them down okay that will help you
practice for any interviews or or
conversations that you have all right
and then as far as any other areas like
resumes or cover letters or some of the
other things that we touched on today we
have we have a whole host of events out
on the past events calendar and other
coaches have done some phenomenal
webinars on things like address I think
there's even one out there on addressing
the skill gap minding the gap
transferable skills there's just so much
out there so I invite you to pay
attention to those those will really
help you clickable just cuz you're
overqualified it just means you need to
tweak it slightly so that's what we're
talking about here today all right all
right
so moving on you're going to also
address it in your cover letter and I
will just tell you that it's very
important not to skirt the issue here
okay so if you know for sure that you
are overqualified in some areas for a
job your plank or you want to address it
head-on and in the cover letter you
might say something like while I'm
successfully served for many years as a
senior product manager I am a kind of
more of a tangible role in future
technological developments by using my
programming talents or something like
that you need to think through the why
and this is where all of this
soul-searching and everything that I've
talked about earlier really prepares you
for the cover letter and even for your
networking and your elevator pitch okay
and then in terms of the interview you
have to be able to talk about this
confidently talking about it with people
in your network ahead of time will help
you prepare for the interview have them
ask you questions if you're not making
the case for them if you haven't
convinced them or yourself you're not
going to convince the hiring supervisor
okay all right I'm gonna move a little
faster I see that I'm getting down to
the last 15 minutes so I'm gonna skip
this part I just want to tell you that
as you are explaining this and all your
materials and all your verbal
conversation these are the third the
three or four things that I want you to
really think about a message has to be
consistent it has to have a consistent
theme it has to be convincing it also
has to be a compelling story all of the
communication the written the verbal all
of that should follow a consistent theme
and it means to demonstrate confidence
one
thing about the piece that I guess
actually will be back for the next slide
what you'll want to do as you're
creating your communication both your
oral communication and your written is
you want to think through that list of
employer fears and you want to address
those head-on for the most part if it's
not appropriate to list it like there's
going to be some things you wouldn't
want to put in your resume
you're not going to dress the salary
question or the commitment question how
long you're willing to stay but you need
to think about what if I'm asked about
this it could be a very pointed question
like so I see that you've been doing
this for a while and you're applying for
this job and I just wonder how long are
you gonna be introduced and you need to
be prepared for that question and you
need to be listening in the interview in
case they don't ask that question
directly but you feel like it's
appropriate to try to bring that up and
there are ways to do that and that is
something that we can talk about in a
coaching session you can say you know I
understand that you know that there
there might be kind of a mismatch based
on what I've done before and that there
could be some areas where it's perceived
that I'm overqualified for this position
but I want you to know that I've been
thinking about this a lot and I'm very
passionate about learning more so that I
can contribute in a different way that I
missed the hands-on piece and that's why
I went to you daddy learn about
artificial intelligence because I really
find that an exciting area and I want
you to know I understand the disconnect
but I'm prepared to make you know a
commitment if you if you are prepared to
make a commitment and then I really
think I have something to contribute
here okay we can walk through those
things in a coaching session if you need
some help crafting
all right so as you're doing this I want
you to think about I want you to do a
visualization exercise um this one I
want you to imagine that the person that
the person who hire you um is looking at
you interact with your colleagues okay
just imagine that you are that person
and that you are looking at you interact
with your colleagues or work on or
explain a project or whatever seems to
be kind of applying for and I want you
to imagine they are smiling at you or
smiling at themselves and saying to
themselves that they made a grade higher
because they hire you what would you be
doing in that moment that would make
them say that write it all down and can
you do these things you know not then
take and genuine way maybe it's helping
a colleague problem-solve work on a
programming project maybe it's giving
credit to somebody else for their role
maybe it's help you know helping work
through a team conflict so glad that
they hire you for okay so that's just a
little exercise you can take away with
you and and write it all down these are
things those notes and assure you
revisit your notes those are things that
will help you prepare for the interviews
that you'll have try them out this is
your elevator pitch try this out you
know talk about why you're making this
career change talk about it on your
LinkedIn talk about it to your your
colleagues your friends your family ask
for their feedback ask them if they're
convinced
did I did I convince you why I want to
do huh that's okay this will help you
prepare the more you get comfortable the
more you'll be confident when you make
your pitch and when you talk about this
in an interview and then where you'll
convince the hiring manager which is
what really counts that they should hire
you okay
now I think I might have talked a bit
about this already if I did I'm sorry I
do want you to keep your ego in check
that you are nice and as you're talking
particularly an interview you know when
you're overqualified sometimes it's easy
for us to think oh yeah no problem I've
done that a hundred times I can do that
standing on my head
do not do that interview okay you don't
want to undersell yourself but you don't
want to oversell yourself either and you
don't want to come across as egotistical
or or too overconfident
particularly in those situations where
the supervisor the hiring manager is
already feeling a little bit of concern
about maybe you outshining them or maybe
it's going to be uncomfortable for them
to supervise you because you have done
things they haven't done you want to be
very careful about that okay and then
you know really what we've talked about
so far it's very much like that aligning
your head in your heart with your goals
and if you were still struggling and
you're not sure that is all in line that
is going to cause you to demonstrate
doubt and I encourage you to go back
through and work on it more and really
question yourself whether you're making
the right decision and if you are get
some help if you're stuck in a
particular area all right understand
what really makes you doubt yourself as
you work through this um you might have
had a situation many of us have we're
you know a particular job you had was a
short job from any any particular reason
maybe you left there sooner than you
planned or you left under in
voluntary reasons maybe you even had a
performance termination in your history
and that keeps causing it keeps coming
up for you and it keeps getting in your
way because you can't get past it and
you just cringe at the thought that the
new hiring manager will ask you about
that okay you need to figure out how
you're going to answer that and that's
not always easy but you know kind of a
clue there is to really talk about you
know you need to be honest you have to
be honest in your application process if
they happen to ask you you know where
you rehired a goal you know there ways
to answer that with your lessons learned
and what have you experienced since then
what have you done differently that
makes that no longer an issue anyway
there's more to that we don't have time
to get into the details of that that is
something that a coach can help you with
I already talked about keeping your ego
in check and and I talked about how you
would visualize a successful outcome on
the part of the hiring manager I want
you to do this for yourself on the part
of you the applicant it's really
important that you spend some time
before you go into an interview
visualizing a successful outcome it's
sort of like a meditation practice where
you close your eyes or keep them open
whatever works fast and you say you know
what in the end this is what that's
gonna look like when I am done with this
I will have done this well and I will
have done this but I would have taken a
deep breath I would have been present in
the moment I would have been able to
answer the questions because I'm prepare
I'm going to take a deep sigh of relief
because it's all over and I'm gonna feel
really good about how I presented myself
okay so somebody you just came off mute
I'm sometimes asked how do I actually
make this transition happen I'm gonna
software engineer for 20 years and I
wanna do machine learning but I can't
figure out how to do
well one idea is is first check the
current company if you're employed
currently what what opportunities does
your current employer have even if you
don't see yourself staying with them
that many more years I mean it you don't
really know so again you want to be um
see if you can find a different job at
your current company where you know
cobble together a couple of jobs if you
have an employer that's really flexible
they I really want to get involved in
this but I don't really want to leave
what I'm doing so can we come up with
something where I can you know I know
about these problems over here maybe I
can help this project team work on that
they'd love to spend X hours of my
schedule doing that that's a great way
to think about the ways there's other
ways to make that transition and I'm
sure some of you even have ideas on that
so anyway hopefully we'll be able to
capture this but um think about you know
what are all the ways maybe you there
isn't that same opportunity so you're
gonna have to switch companies you need
to do some really good research and make
sure you're getting a company that has
the jobs that you're interested in and
then you need to think about for all
those sort of not so intuitive ways you
know can you volunteer
maybe there's a local public agency that
needs help with a programming problem
and maybe you could volunteer to work on
that also think about other ways to
build the salary gap and in this let you
know maybe there's maybe there's you
know something you could do part-time
maybe you're all in working three five
forty hours a week and maybe there's a
different side job you could take on and
that would help with a salary gap
startups are another place to think
about partly because they're genuinely
in the mindset of taking some risk and
so
um you or olive side might be risky but
they might be willing and to look the
other way on that or see you as the
asset and advantage that you are um the
other thing with that is they're not so
structured in their job descriptions
they just need people that can help get
their business up and running right and
you might be one of those people
so anyway I'm sure I've missed some
things and I'm moving kind of fast here
um but um let's see all right so let's
assume you get the job that's great
yay you got the job you did all the
things right and you got lucky enough to
land this job and you again you take
sure to take credit for all the work you
did but now you're hired it's time to go
to work
don't forget the integrity in this
process don't do a bait-and-switch on
your employer they hired you you need
you you offered something to them you
needed something from them they need
something from you offer you this job
that's the proposition you need to
remember that remember how you pitch
yourself remember the commitments you
made and just spend the next year or two
or whatever it takes to focus on adding
value how can you add value think about
how you can help other sixteenth notes
there those are some ways to give back
all right
um the other thing that we just say that
is if you are not successful the first
time or two that you approach this take
note of what you can learn from this I
mean this is a you would do this anyway
whether you're qualified or
overqualified or not every interview
every job search is an opportunity to
debrief on what you can learn think
about take notes after your interviews
after your conversations you stumbled on
about where your gut is wrenching and
what you need to figure out about that
so it doesn't come up again think about
what makes you nervous
this is often things are really key
because if we can change our thoughts
around something maybe something's
really bothering you from your past and
you need to work through that in your
past employment situation um you can
actually change your feelings which
thoughts plus feelings equals action
behavior anyway I know that was really
fast and I want to thank you for
participating we have about four minutes
and I want to thank Brett for managing
the chat so I didn't have to try to do
too much multitasking here what else
[Music]
Diana wanted to bring up some of the
common questions that we were getting in
the checks I think some people might be
having some similar issues and so one of
the major questions that I was seeing
was that people were nervous about
having the conversations and answering
some of those common questions that you
and told them to prepare for and so I
know we just want to reiterate the
importance of that and not just knowing
what questions they might ask but
actually preparing potential responses
or those and so for any one of you out
there who saw that list of questions
that Diane presented don't just have an
understanding of that they might ask
those questions take some time to
actually either write it out or type it
out or prepare some bullet points that
you might actually address it doesn't
necessarily have to be rehearsed but it
can be helpful to have that prepared
because as it relates to the interview
process all of those worries and those
concerns that are contributing to the
lack of confidence are coming from your
lack of preparation and so if you take
the time to prepare responses to those
questions it reduces some of the
nervousness around that and I think
Diane you did a great job of mentioning
that point another
thing that I wanted to talk about was
people you know have mentioned in the
chat something about preparing responses
to those questions but not necessarily
having the experiences to back them up
and so that's another point that I
wanted to mention is when you're
preparing responses to these questions
it's also important to think proactively
about how you can address those gaps
instead of just focusing on answering
those questions so even know that
they're going to ask you a question
about a skill gap let's say for example
you have ten years of leading teams but
you have less experience with a certain
tool instead of saying that you know
that you need to work on that tool tell
them that you recently started working
on an online class that directly focuses
on that specific tool or that specific
skill set don't just tell them that you
know you need that skill tell them how
you've actually been working towards
that and all of these things you can do
in advance if you're doing the research
of those job descriptions yes one last
thing was anytime people mention
something like a potential red flag so
whether you're overqualified whether you
have a resume gap weather whatever I
would consider those to be kind of like
on paper red flags which are always
going to have a potential negative
impact depending on the person who's
reading it and so this is where I want
to drive home the point in the
importance of networking in relationship
building because those on paper red
flags become a lot less worrisome for
employers when they actually know who
you are as a person and so if you have
anything on your resume that might be
potentially seen as a red flag that's
why it's important for you to focus on
that relationship building piece so you
can be as competitive as possible with
the people who may have a better resume
or just a better reference or skills
that's excellent breath thank you so
much for sharing that getting really
sick it really needs to spend some time
as he said writing it down and then the
networking piece is just invaluable
thank you so much for yep no problem
great all right well thank you for
joining us we've come to the end of our
hour and um I know that I the other
coaches join me and and welcoming you to
schedule a session with us if we can be
helpful to you so please feel free to do
that
and please um have a great day and I
hope that our paths cross soon
[Music]